>> Thanks for coming
and thanks Sumit
for offering your
precious time to visit us.
Actually, he is one of us.
He started Microsoft
Research, and of course,
we were very proud of
what he has achieved.
He started in rise.
He's the main architect
of Pendleton and leads,
which is a data wrangling tool,
a data ingestion tool.
He leads the PROSE group
that does that.
When I read the abstract,
he was joking about
a mid-life crisis and it's
shocking. He's way too young.
Rico and I, we can joke
about our mid-life crisis,
but you haven't
earned the right yet.
You're way too young for that.
But anyway we're really
looking forward to your talk.
>> Okay, thanks Donald
for the introduction.
It's an awesome feeling
to be back in
my home building here.
So my research career
has not spend 18 years.
And in this second half
of this career,
I have led a different
research lifestyle
than what I had in
the first half
and this has given
me much more personal
satisfaction.
And this is a story that I
want to share with you today.
Unsurprisingly, the story
starts with my mid-life crisis.
So I saved enough to buy my BMW.
I had won some amazing awards.
I had a decent amount
of publications,
citation counts, H-index,
and it was climbing steadily.
But then there wasn't-.
>> How much for BMW?
>> But some form of
deeper meaning was lacking.
The work that I was
doing, I felt was not
as much significant for
the society and the legacy
that it would possibly lead.
This inspired me to start
looking for fixing
this situation.
The idea was clear,
I wanted to transition to
different value systems.
Now, by no means,
these value systems are novel.
In fact, they are very simple,
but the reason why I am excited
to talk about them today
is that they are
unreasonably effective.
In fact, many of
you might actually
already be following
these kinds of value systems.
However, I have to admit that
the academic world of which
we are all products off,
does not emphasize
these value systems
as much as it should.
The reason why I called them
Big Bets is because that
the transition to
these value systems was not
easy because change
is usually hard.
I was very intentional
about making the switch.
This is something that required
a huge amount of effort.
It makes up for an interesting
story to be shared.
However, the most
important thing here is
that these were
just not my bets.
I did not simply bet
on these value systems,
but I also bet on the people
who are involved
with this transition.
This was a bet that
even those people made.
was even made by
the people who funded
these arrangements.
So this is a story of
several of us together.
Before I describe
these four bets,
let me actually
provide some context in
terms of the research agenda
that I was working on,
and I would explain these bets
in that specific context.
The problem that
had taken most of
my interest was
the soft program synthesis.
The goal here is to automatically
search for a program in
an underlying
domain-specific language
from some natural form of
intent provided by the user,
either in the form
of input/output
examples or natural language.
In fact, this had
been an old problem,
almost as old programming,
but not much success
was achieved back then.
In the past decade, we have seen
some significant advances
in this area.
Thanks to much better algorithms
and faster machines.
In fact, just to boast
what we have achieved now,
a few months ago,
we conducted an experiment
with some Python programmers.
We gave them
a data cleaning task,
and they took on average,
30 minutes to finish this task.
We can do the same task using
our program synthesis APIs
in 30 seconds.
Program synthesis can really
improve the productivity of
developers by
one to two hours of
magnitude in
certain tasks domains.
But, what gets me
even more excited
is the potential that it
can enable non-programmers to
create small scripts for
automating repetitive tasks.
Ninety nine percent
people who have
computers do not
know programming.
And these people struggle
with repetitive tasks in
their lives but these
are not stupid people.
They just don't know the
artificial programming language
of speaking to a computer.
But program synthesis
technologies
can enable these people to
achieve much more
in their lives now,
because they can use computers
much more effectively.
This is a context of
the research that I was in,
and when I had
this mid-life crisis,
I was working on
program synthesis for
trying to help
algorithm designers
and hardcore
software developers.
And the kinds of tasks that
we were looking at was to
synthesize textbook algorithms
like sorting algorithms,
or to synthesize
tricky pieces of
code that even humans would
take years or two
to come up with.
And this had to change.
So the first bet that I
placed was to be able to
connect to the customers
more directly
because this kind of
program synthesis was not
able to achieve
the kind of dream
that I just outlined
earlier to be able to help
developers in their regular
tasks or to be able to
help non-programmers with
the task that they
struggle with.
In this old world,
the way I would choose
the problem that I
would go solve would
be mostly inspired by
what will help me publish
a paper in a
top-tier conference.
What is the next incremental
or foundational
improvement that I can
do which can get me
a next paper in a top-tier
research conference.
And the way I would define
my success metrics would be
to either come up with
a benchmark myself.
In fact, I have written
papers which just get
cited by the benchmarks
that I chose
there and those benchmarks
are just made
up from some imagination
one afternoon.
The other way I would choose the
benchmarks would be to just
follow what other people
would use in their papers.
And this is the stuff that had
to change if I really wanted to
connect with real people
and change their lives.
So in this new world, I found
a lot of inspiration from
help forums by trying to
understand what were the pain
points of different users.
In fact, more
recently, we have been
conducting exercises
like Moneyball.
Wherefore, six weeks we do
nothing but just try to
connect to customers,
we write scripts to figure
out contact information of
customers from different
social networking sites.
We email them to try
to set up a phone call.
If phone call looks promising,
we invite them to
a workshop at Microsoft.
After running that workshop,
we figure out what did
not work well and we
repeat the process for
the other three weeks.
In fact, when we
do our releases,
we are very cognizant
of putting in
proper telemetry and be able
to get feedback from users.
So this is a world
that I wanted to be
in and the transition
point came.
So, there is this one instant
that I like to share here.
So I was coming back
in an airplane after
presenting some program
synthesis innovations at
the workshop and
there was a lady
sitting next to me
and she was very
impressed to know that I worked
for Microsoft and
that I had a PhD.
So she thought I better
ought to be able to help her
with the Excel tasks that
she was struggling with.
She opened up
her machine and asked
me how she can do one
transformation on her column.
And at that time, I have
to excuse myself out
of the situation because I
did not had any knowledge
about the programming
model inside Excel.
But that gave me a hint
that these are the kinds of
simple tasks that I need to
or I should consider
going after,
as opposed to trying to come up
with tricky big
vector algorithms or
reinvent sorting algorithms
which have been known for
ages because that research
is not going to help anyone.
So I spent months
trying to study
spreadsheet help forums to
figure out what problem
should I be solving,
which simplest problem can
yield the biggest benefit,
and what should be
the initial target benchmarks
that I should be working with.
This was a typical interaction
that I noticed on
the help forum.
An end user would ask
an expert on the help forum,
"Can you please
give me a script or
a program that can convert
the string on the left side of
this arrow to
this thing on the right
side of this arrow?".
The expert would look at this
input/output example and will
provide a script that
would say extract two characters
starting at the fifth character.
Now, the end user will take
this program and figure out
that it doesn't do the right job
at this other input.
The expert looks at it
again and probably tries
to have a better model of
the intent that the user has.
So what do you think is
the end user trying to do here?
Yes, so extract everything that
is between the first
two underscores.
And do you know
how do you program,
how would you program
this in Excel?
So Excel has
a programming model,
and this is one of the simplest
programs that you can write.
So even if you know programming,
you will have to go to
stack overflow or some kind of
documentation to
figure out what is
the API that Excel exposes.
But you are the lucky one,
the one percent people
who know programming.
Think about 99 percent people
who do not know programming,
they will be stuck.
On this case the end user
takes as a script and run set,
and sends a thank
you to the expert.
And this is a feature that we
designed, which
shipped in Excel,
in 2013 and was quite it
received quite a good reception.
So it also led me publishing
this particular paper.
So this is one of
the necklaced papers
that I've published
in my career.
Most of those papers had the
similar kind of
intellectual depth,
but this is the one
that I'm most known for.
So why do you think
this is the case?
This is because, not only
this work appeared in
a top-tier conference,
but this work also solves
a problem that
real people care about,
that shipped in Excel,
and this is something
that I would
say does not happen that often.
It is very easy to
do one of the two.
Write software that is used
by millions of people
everyone in office does that,
or write a research paper
and all researchers do that.
But the intersection
is one which is really
makes this paper special.
Now several people
often comment that Sumit
got lucky because he
worked at Microsoft,
so he figured out
the problem from there
and the Excel team you know
gave him the benchmarks.
The truth is
even the Excel team,
was inspired from us,
looking at help forums
to figure out
what the target
benchmark should be.
They didn't really give
us that much benchmark,
they didn't really help us
much in terms of benchmarks.
And the way I went about
identifying
the problem definition
and figuring out the benchmark
is something that
any academic would have possibly
done themselves as well,
they didn't need to be
inside Microsoft to do that.
The question really is,
would they be willing
to spend three months
doing nothing just
looking at help forums?
And that is what
this change was all about.
That is that the risk,
the bet that I took in
my career which I think
paid off quite well.
It really is
a funny story about how
we even got this paper accepted.
So few days before
I was about to
submit this paper
to this conference,
I started going through
the email where I had
accepted the invitation to
be on the PC for
this conference,
to just see how strict
the standards would
be for PC submissions.
And then I realized it said,
single-authored submissions
from PC members not allowed.
And then I sent a mail
to the chair saying,
I believe this is
the most important paper
in my life that I have
written about until now.
And I happen to have agreed to
this weird requirement
that you have.
Do you want me to include
my wife's name on the paper?
And then within
a few hours an email
gets sent out to
all the PC members saying,
I want to leave this requirement
unless you know someone
has an objection.
And that paved the way for
me to submit this paper.
And this really changed how I
started conducting this search
after this point onwards.
After we got addicted
to this kind of success,
we wanted to now apply
this kind of
programming by examples,
to many new different domains.
So instead of just doing
string transformations,
we applied it to doing
number transformations
for instance.
Even a task as simple as
rounding a number to
two decimal places,
requires you to remember
different kinds of
"Format Descriptors"
in different languages.
But again examples
had a very natural way
to specify intent here.
Or maybe think of a task
which is a bit more involved,
and you will have to spend
several minutes trying to
think of a script to
do this conversion.
But again, these are
the kinds of tasks that
now we can do with
a few examples.
We applied it to the domain of
extracting tabular data
from locked files.
This is an assignment taken
from a data science class,
where the instructor
asks the students
to extract that tabular data
that you see on the right side,
and the instructor gives
them a script to start with.
So the goal is to
take this script
and build on it to go
from left to right.
But the expedients
were designed,
all that the user it has to do,
is to give an example of two of
the various fields that
they want to extract,
and then will
automatically be able to
extract other instances
of that field.
We applied it to manipulating
semi-structured spreadsheets.
Turns out 50% Excel spreadsheets
are semi-structured and the task
of going from the left to
the right is usually
quite involved.
But again this
can be facilitated
by simply a few examples.
So this application domain
that I mentioned to
you can be clumped
into what is called,
data transformations
or data-wrangling.
And this is where
data scientists apparently spend
80% of their time
before they can
bring data into a form
where they can apply
machine [inaudible]
in order to be able
to build interesting models.
Another killer application
is, quote transformations.
If you want to help users or
developers migrate their quote
from one platform
to another one,
from an old version
of a framework
to a new version
of their framework.
In such migration scenarios,
they are apparently spending
40% percent of their time,
doing their protective
quote edits.
But again this is a scenario
where they can give
one or two examples of
the adage they want,
and the system can
automatically suggest them all
of the places where they might
want to do such transformations.
So huge range of
applications basically.
This is the thing that I want
to really emphasize here.
But how did all of this
actually come about?
Even starting with the fact
that I told you that you know
this bubble paper that
I wrote on "Flash Fill".
I spent three months,
just studying the help forums.
And only three weeks
coming up with
an algorithm and implementing it
and maybe a couple
of other weeks
writing the draft of the paper.
But then it took
two years to ship
this product with Excel
and it was no mean feat.
The first support
that I got was from
my manager at
the time, Ben Zorn,
who played the perfect
selfless role of
ensuring that this technology
actually meets its right fit.
It was very hard for me to even
connect with the right
sort of people in
Excel in order to be able to
show them this technology.
But Ben had the right sort of
context and he facilitated that.
We had an artist D who devoted
himself for one or two years
in order to be able to do this
tech transfer over at Excel.
We had a PM Shobana
Balakrishnan,
who played the right role,
in dealing with
the upper management
as well as the people
on the ground,
in order to get
this technology shipped out.
I think the start of the show
has to be the Rishabh Singh,
who came here for
three different internships and
when his OPT finally ran out
we shipped him to India so
that he can work
for us from there.
He took this technology
to a completely new level.
There were many interns
who followed,
who worked on these different
variations that I talked
about like extracting
data from locked files,
extracting tabular data from
semi-structured spreadsheets.
Gustavo who worked on,
doing quote transformations
from examples.
Mark who is in the room here,
who led work on programming
by natural language.
There is one important character
missing on this slide.
Who would you guess, what
the role of that
character would be?
So I'm talking about
my partners here, right?
>> Your wife. She
was the coauthor.
>> Three internships.
Two internships are
contractor position.
Two-year postdoc.
Almost like another
one year of funding.
Where does this
funding come from?
So these are the funding Gods
who enabled this arrangement.
So, Rico was running
this impossible things
initiative at that time.
And he took bet on
this technology,
so that it can actually
see where it ought to be.
So now, we invested into
so many different kinds
of task domains for
program synthesis,
but there was one big challenge
that developing each of
these program synthesizers
was a very tedious effort.
It required you to think of
an algorithm from the beginning.
It required you to you
to do an implementation
and if you want to do
a robust implementation,
you have to spend
months engineering it.
And also people in academia
started rumors that,
"Oh, Sumit is not only
doing practical research."
So it was now time for payback.
And all the environment was well
set up for the second bet.
Which was to develop
a framework that can
facilitate the design and
development of these kinds of
program synthesizers for
various individual domains.
So in the old Word,
we would invent
a program synthesis algorithm
from scratch for
a new domain and we had
worked on 20 such domains.
And each of them would
be publishable in
a top-tier conference and
we can keep continuing
the crank there.
But we want to do
something better.
So we wanted to develop
a framework that
would be parameterized by
various domain-specific
concepts.
So that it can guide
our algorithmic thinking,
it can make the time to engineer
a robust synthesizer from
months to a few weeks.
And furthermore, this will
also pave way for
doing new research.
But now the new research
that will be
done will actually provide
value for all
different domains as
opposed to being
domain-specific.
So this is how the framework
actually looks like.
So in the old Word,
you would have a synthesizer
for each domain.
Which will take as
input examples and will output
the program and this is
the model insight Flash Fill is,
but the first kind of
parameterization that we
did here was that instead of
having the search algorithm to
be very domain-specific and
having a separate
search algorithm
for each different domain,
we parameterized
this search algorithm with
the underlying
domain-specific language
in which we wanted to
synthesize programs.
So now to develop a synthesizer
for a different domain,
you can plug in a separate
domain-specific language.
Another interesting
point here is
that examples are a very
ambiguous form of user's intent.
When you give me
one or two examples,
the number of programs
in my domain-specific
language that
match those examples is
often 10 to the power 50.
So we need to pick a program
that we believe matches
that user's intent.
And if we don't get this right,
Excel will not see Flash Fill.
In fact, they demanded that for
most simple tasks we ought
to read the mind of the user
from just one input/output
example because otherwise
people would lose trust in
this technology. They
would not use it.
It will come up with
funny interpretations.
And the ranking
algorithm that we used
was intertwined with
the search algorithm.
But this was a good opportunity
to separate the two
things together.
So now the search algorithm
returns a program set,
the set of all programs that
match the examples
and now we have
a separate ranker which
can take the program set and
introduce a rank program set.
And furthermore, this ranker
can be parameterized by
different kinds of
ranking functions or features.
We can also build
interactivity in this loop.
We can actually
guide the user in
deciding if they need to
provide us more examples or not.
And once we believe
that they might have
a correct program,
we can show them the program in
our domain-specific language
which can then
be translated to a new language
of choice like Python,
R, C Sharp or Java.
So this is what the overall
structure architecture looks
like. But how did we get here?
>> Question.
> Yeah.
>> So for the user input,
you are exposing
it to the user in
the domain-specific language and
the other motivation you have is
the user who doesn't
know programming, right?
>> Yes. It is a good question.
So the end user only interacts
with the red color hair.
>> Okay.
>> The blue color is done by
researchers or
advanced developers like us.
So Vu Le had
developed this system
called Flash Extract which
would extract tabular data
from log files.
And we wanted to also
extend this work to be able
to extract data from web pages,
extract data from
semi-structure documents.
And then he ended up doing
another implementation
of Flash Extract for log files,
so that it becomes general
enough that we can also extract,
use the same framework
to extract data from
the web pages,
from spreadsheets.
And this resulted
in some kind of
generalization and a step
towards this framework.
We had another intern
Dileep Kini who worked
on extending Flash Fill
to doing much more
complicated tasks.
So he experimented with
new interaction models,
he experimented with
new synthesis techniques.
And I would say it
was a mild success.
It resulted in a paper,
but did not make as much dent
as we had hoped for.
But these were
kind of fine steps,
two fine steps
towards the process.
Around the same time, I had
an intern Alex Polozov who
is actually in the room,
who was being randomized by
me on many different kinds of
projects and he was watching
this thing happening
from the sidelines.
And then he came to me and
he said, "You know Sumit,
I can solve the problem
that you are looking
to solve here."
But he was not clear
whether he would want
to solve it or not.
How will this actually work out
because he was a student at
UDub and solving this problem
really require a big dedication.
I convinced him several weeks
and then finally he decided
that he will actually
be doing his PhD at
Microsoft Research,
working full-time on
this particular project.
And so he did, he actually
solved this problem.
And I think there is a beautiful
paper that he authored.
But while he was focused on
developing the nuts and
bolts of the framework,
we acquired Vu to
reimplement Flash Extract
yet another time.
So first he implemented
Flash Extract for log files.
Actually, that was
a second implementation of
Flash Extract for log files
because it was one
other person Herman Venter
who had developed
the first implementation but
unfortunately he left
the company after a year.
Then Vu developed
Flash Extract the second time.
Vu implemented Flash Extract
the third time so that we can
generalize it not just to
log files but to other formats.
And then, he provided
great service to Alex by
reimplementing Flash Extract in
the most general framework
that we now have.
So four times implementation
of Flash Extract.
And not only that
other interns who were
also around or who
could participate
tried to reimplement
what they had done in
the framework that
Alex proposed.
So just imagine the amount
of investment that
is going into this.
Implementing Flash Extract
the fourth time.
What business value
is that adding?
And who on earth would
fund that effort?
Rico, I gave a lot of you know
probably too much
credit last time when I
said that you funded
Flash Fill and Flash
Extract because
any sane person would want to
throw money at that, right?
It's so cool, it just looks
so cool from this concept.
But who would put money on this?
This is the real credit
that actually Rico gets.
Again, months of internship,
paying for the stipend of
Alex for the entire year,
paying his tuition,
it is quite expensive
but this is the place where
Rico really put
his foot forward.
And I'm not sure if he trusted,
he put a bet on the project
but probably he also
put a bet on me.
So it was his bet on
both the technology
as well as people.
Now, what was
the next problem here?
So I have to tell you
that Alex is a talent.
He's one of the best engineers
that I've known and
he could deal with
the sophisticated theory
that is there inside this paper.
It's hard to find gems
like him, absolutely hard.
I cannot not just
manufacture new
Alex's and put them together.
And also he needs
to be left alone to
decide his own paths
and directions in life.
So how can I carry forward
this mission where I really need
to take this framework and
make it production quality.
If we just continue to
depend upon in interns,
this is not going to work out.
Because interns
are going to leave,
they can come for
three internships,
they can again
extend the contract
for another six months.
We can continue to get
angel funding from Rico,
but this model is
not going to sustain.
So something has to really
change and this brings me to
the third bet which
is about my belief
off putting research and
engineering together.
So if you recall the success of
Flash Fill relied on
two years of engagement
with the Excel team,
where we had built
a research prototype and
the Excel team took it
and copied it
line-by-line into C++.
So our C Sharp code was
copied line-by-line into C++.
And if they had
any performance issues
or some bugs that needed to fix,
they would get back
to us, we would fix
it in our code and then
they would take it.
But we want to do
more such things
and you want to
accelerate them, right?
So using this model of what we
call Tech Transfer is
not going to work here.
We have to build and
deliver that tech ourselves.
>> Did you consider
the option to open
source and therefore get
more traction for the software
that you were building?
>> That's an
interesting question
and my feel is
that time is still
not right before we
get there because we're
still in the early stages.
I think the project
needs to be matured up to
a certain level when
open sourcing will
start adding value.
Also my role up until now
was more of an
individual contributor.
Of course I was working
with many collaborators,
I was involved with
20 projects in the year.
And in one year, I was
working with a total of
50 people on those 20 projects.
So I was not alone.
But I was still,
what I will call
an individual contributor.
I was splitting my time
into multiple projects,
spending five percent of
my time on this project,
10 percent of my time on
this project and these
were all disparate projects.
Some may be loosely connected.
But what we needed was a team,
which will have a shared mission
and which will
actually work together.
So I sometimes joke and
explain my situation,
this past situation if
individual contributor as,
I was having multiple
girlfriends at the same time.
Which was of course
a very thrilling situation.
But now, with a team,
it is like being
settled in a family,
where everyone has
the same mission
and working towards
the same thing.
And another thing that got me
quite inspired from one
of Peter Lee's slides
on different quadrants is
the appreciation of two
different styles of research.
One of which he called
long-term Blue-Sky research
and the other thing was
shot-term mission-focused.
And I used to think that,
at some point of time,
I need to be in one
of those quadrants.
But this is the assumption
that I started
challenging and now what
I believe is that we
ought to fund
Blue-Sky research by using
mission-focused deliverables
and we need to find
synergies between
these two goals.
So how would this research and
engineering be put together?
So here is a slide
that I have try to
capture some of
my thoughts here.
So first, I notice that there is
a quite a parallelism between
the research world and
the engineering world.
And both those worlds
have appreciation for
long-term processes as well as
short-term value proposition
that they offer.
So work like Flash Fill will
actually fit in this bucket.
Where our goal is to work
on the next shiny thing,
write a research paper,
make a quick impact.
They work on Flash meta.
This is our framework
that Alex built,
will fall in this bucket here.
And normally, what
we would do is,
we will do multiple instantiations
first like Flash Fill,
Flash Extract, Flash Normalize,
Flash Relate and will then
try to generalize
them into a framework.
This is the old World, this is
the old typical academic World.
But now for a change,
what if we productize
the framework and
then we start building
innovation on top
of that framework.
And this is a new world which
will speed-up innovation.
Also by trying to do something
cool and then trying
to figure it out,
what kind of consumers
or customers can have
a impact or in which product
can I put my technology.
That's a very fine way
of doing things.
But I think in the new world,
what I would like
to do things is
completely the other way around.
Where I would first
like to connect with
customers and try to
understand what are some
of the relevant problems.
So that I don't waste
my time trying to
solve problems which
are not as relevant.
And both problems are equally
intellectually interesting.
But if I have a choice,
I would rather pick
something that is more relevant.
And furthermore, if I set up
my engineering processes right,
then all of
these three quadrants
are going to actually have
a push onto innovation.
So even if I end up spending
a fraction of my time
in this quadrant,
the fact that I've invested here
and these other quadrants
is actually going
to push and accelerate
the development of new ideas
and their delivery.
So this is what we also
see with the interns
that we sometimes get.
So I had experience where,
if I get a very smart student
but who is not that
great at engineering.
They actually sometimes struggle
because with the limited time
that they have,
they're able to
tryout only few ideas.
But someone who's
probably not as
good but a much
strong engineer is
sometimes more successful
because they're able to try
out many more ideas in
the same amount of time.
So this is the kind of
a structure that I wanted,
where engineers and researchers
would be working
synergistically.
And this is the team
that I now have,
where the goal of
researchers is not to
develop prototypes
and throw it to
engineers for them
to productize.
So researchers have to do
product quality implementation
of their ideas.
But I do acknowledge
the fact that,
not everyone is like Alex.
People are not trained,
to be great software engineers.
But as long as the engineers
on the team are
willing to give the
researchers guidance,
on how to do right
software engineering.
And as long as
researchers are open to
picking up on it,
it will work out.
And this is the arrangement that
I have on my team right now.
And furthermore, it's teamwork.
So while every researcher
on the team has
their ownership of
some important capability,
all these capabilities
are coming
together towards
a common mission.
It's not like
everyone is trying to
create their own islands
of excellence.
So as a Research Manager,
my responsibility
is to make sure that
every researcher in the team
shines, with whatever they do.
But it also all
coherently fits together
as part of one
single big mission.
So many people think,
that I'm running a product team
or an engineering team.
This is completely not true.
I'm running as strong
a research team as you might
find inside this building.
The only reason why I moved out,
was because I did not want to be
a burden on MSR or
more of a drain on MSR.
I wanted to leave
the angel investors like
Rico free to fund
new entrepreneurs like Sumit.
This is the kind of model which
I believe is more sustainable.
This is the message that
I want to spread around,
that product groups should
fund research not just
as a philanthropic activity
but it can really
increase their business,
it can really bring them
distinguish value
to their business.
And if we start
thinking like this,
there's a huge amount
of money in this world.
Now, outside of this small
little organization
that we live in.
And it is inside this
outside world that we should
be seeking real funding that
goes beyond angel investing.
So this is a message that I
really want to share here.
So now last the final bet,
and this is about
my belief in
Cross-Disciplinary Research.
The initial bug actually hit me,
when I was working
with the Nebosh.
Who was part of the reason
why I even joined
Microsoft Research,
Redmond in the first place.
Because we saw
potential off applying
machine learning for
program synthesis.
But sorry Nebosh,
I didn't followup
too much on that after
the initial project.
But more recently, this
has come to be very true.
So Cross-Disciplinary
Research is hard.
For many reasons,
it is difficult
to explain to
the other community
that you have done
something meaningful.
It is difficult to receive
funding in that thing,
you're not really
a expert in that area.
So what you typically do,
right? You might just ignore it.
You may ignore it
for various reasons.
One reason you might ignore it
is that you really believe that,
your community has
the right tools and
techniques to take
a stab at that problem.
Or you might ignore it
because you simply don't care.
It's like Ostrich hiding
its head inside the sand,
or the other option that
you have to remain in
awe of the other kind
of technology.
And the change that I'm now
imbibing in my new world,
is the belief that the third
wave of AI will actually
combine the techniques from
my area which is that
of formal methods,
logical reasoning
techniques, and
from that of the machine
learning community,
all the statistical
learning that is their.
But how would I go about
doing this
Cross-disciplinary Research.
I'm not an expert in this area.
I really need to find the right
empathetic expert
who is willing to be
a partner because
simple collaborations
for the sake of writing
a paper are not going to help
and push this thing
much farther.
So let me actually
explain to you
what are the opportunities for,
why I believe that combining
logic and machine learning is
quite important for creating
many different kinds
of AI software.
So, here's some
intelligent piece
of some software that
behaves intelligently,
and three instances of
such pieces would be
the three components
that I showed you
in this framework for
program synthesis.
One was the search algorithm,
the ranking algorithm, and
the disambiguation algorithm.
So such an intelligent component
is often composed of
two different pieces:
logical strategies or algorithms
that we understand very
well and something that I would
like to call
creative heuristics.
If I further drill down into
the creative heuristics,
at least another code base,
we find that it is made up
of various kinds of
features and some weights
over those features.
For instance there is a constant
0.8 being used in my code base.
So, I asked a researcher,
"Why did we used 0.8?"
The answer is it just
seems to work well.
But in the new world,
it would be fantastic
if developers or researchers
focus their time on
identifying the right features
and writing what is
a well-understood knowledge and
leave the modern
building exercise
to a machine learning
backed runtime.
This can help us come up
with not only better models
and make us more
effective but it
can also lead to
these systems being
adaptive and personalized.
So just imagine, when Flash Fill
is running on
different user's machines.
If a user is dealing with
the same kind of data
over and over again,
then instead of having to
give two or three examples,
the system can understand their
intent from just one example.
In some cases even 0.1 examples
are zero examples, right?
And I can formalize that
maybe if you're interested,
you can talk to
me after the talk.
So this kind of
adaptivity would be
possible only if we are using
some automated way to fine-tune
the creative heuristics or
the ranking strategies that are
inside underneath the software.
So this kind of division
would facilitate that.
So I can go a little bit
more into this detail
for each of the three components
that I showed you in
the Program Synthesis framework.
So if you recall, there
was a search algorithm
that was parameterized by
a domain-specific language.
And, the domain-specific
language is usually
specified as some rules
in a grammar.
And, we have a fancy search
strategy that we used
to explore that
grammar in order to
figured out the program that
satisfies the user's intent.
And there are lots of
heuristics that we use
actually in order to make this
process scalable and robust.
Which grammar production
to try first or to not try.
Which disjunctive,
which sub-goal
from a disjunction of sub-goals
to explore when we are
trying to make our progress
towards the goal?
And each of these
decisions can actually
be learned from large amounts of
data that we have
and if we use the
right machine learning,
modeling, and learning gear.
Here is another example
of Program Ranking.
So we have many
programs that match
the users input/output examples
but we need to choose
one of those programs.
So we need to have
techniques that can rank
different programs and
this ranking is based upon
syntactic features
of the program
or even features of the outputs
produced by two or
three different programs
on a given set of inputs.
Now, what weights do you use
for these different features?
And this is again
something that can be
learned from machine learning.
In fact, some features are
more machine learning
than logical like,
"Is this string
the name of a person?"
And in the disambiguation box
that I showed you,
we need to communicate
some actionable information
to the user so
that the user can
decide if they need to
provide more examples
or are they done?
We can show user
some corner cases
where they need to
provide more examples.
But there are many
heuristics that are used
inside this process that
can be machine-learnt.
For instance, when to
stop asking questions?
So every question
comes up with some kind
of probability or threshold.
And if it above the threshold,
we will present it to the user.
But what is that threshold?
Or if we want to cluster
the inputs based upon
their syntactic structure,
this is again very machine
learning techniques
can be quite useful.
So, in order for us to make
big advances in this area,
my partner in crime
has been Prateek Jain,
who is a world-renowned machine
learning expert at MSRI.
And he received great support
from other colleagues
at the lab.
And then he also
brought in a lot of
resourcing in the form of
interns and research fellows.
And this is what it takes
to start experimenting
with such Cross-Disciplinary
research in a serious way.
And again, all of
this arrangement was
facilitated by Sriram Rajamani,
who is the Lab Director,
who wanted to bet on
this direction of research.
So I'll conclude now.
So I talk to you about
these Four Big Bets that have
brought in a lot of value.
But there are also
new challenges that have come
in and I'll just
summarize those here.
So when we talk about
connecting with customers and
gathering the real
data or maybe in
the form of
telemetry or figuring
out where my AI solution is
not working well so that I
can improve my AI offering.
We are going to have
new challenges with
respect to collecting
data because of
the GDPR requirements.
So an interesting research
problem that this opens up
is how can you get data back
without violating any of
the privacy issues that
can yield you enough information
that you can innovate
on your service.
And we already actually have
a lot of real customer data
and we want to release it in
service of the academic
community and for
other competitors to
try out newer ideas.
But the problem is,
the damn problem is,
that the data is so real that
we just cannot release it.
It is the opposite problem now.
So, we are not trying
to see if we can fake up
this data so that
the real challenges of
synthesis are still
preserved where the data is
completely faked up and then
we can release this data.
The other thing that I
talked about was taking
a framework-based approach
to designing and development.
And, one challenge that of
course always remains is,
how to balance between
specialization and generalization.
Because with a fixed amount
of funding, no resources, time,
either you can structure
something that is
very intelligent for
a vertical domain or
you can do something
that is less intelligent
for a more in
a general purpose layer.
So we always have to make
the right set of choices
there, it is not easy.
I third bet I talked about was
putting research and
engineering together.
And here, it even involves doing
end-to-end delivery
of your offering.
What about maintenance?
Now, you put this thing
out and then are you
committing to maintaining
it indefinitely?
And even people management
isn't interesting
unspoken aspect
here when you are
running a big team of
people working together.
And then the final thing
that I talked about was
the significance of
Cross-Disciplinary Research.
And one challenge
that comes here is,
how do you balance between
doing some quick experiments
versus doing things
in a way so that
you are already, always
production ready.